you need to write down what's with the
jeans
nobody's bad huh still reeling from last
week amazing times with Ryan Sickler yes
Oh before we started the show I want to
plug two plugs up front sure man
plug it at your mommy's Christina and
Tommy and we're gonna be at the Fort
Lauderdale improv next week yeah so come
out and see us okay yeah yeah 5th
through the 8th word both of us so
what's up my players What's Up player
playing is that spring break you guys
gonna be there for spring break is it
that place is bumpin 24/7 and 365
there's there's nothing but fucking
right people no seriously you can't they
you used to be able to go to that the
Hard Rock the Seminole Hard Rock in it's
technically in Hollywood Florida you
could get like deals like you know like
when you go to Vegas know like ah you
know come this come on Tuesday and you
can get a $90 room whatever yeah that
place has become so popular that you
there are no deals and every night's
$300 and it's sold out actually non-stop
I think it's bait I had this
conversation with a guy down there he
was like you realized that like South
Florida is prime for gambling and like
it's all fuckin derelicts and lunatic
it's like the craziest well Florida
itself is Right strange damn bution and
you think about it you go how in my area
not full of casinos right and I grew up
a couple hours north of Miami yeah and
um you know you go once you kind of go
in like into in South of Palm Beach
County
it's all fucking lunatics like it's it's
it's a it's a nighttime like lifestyle
kind of place where everybody parties to
I think staying alive is a gamble in
Miami it's so or sure it's like and and
shanked
I mean people are you you think about
like late-night you understand like
Miami you party easily until 5:00 6:00
in the morning and you can go to after
party
after that but you can go to a party
that starts at 6:00 in the morning okay
okay so game is all about fucking
getting fucked up and so you think like
you realize you like do this is this is
where gambling should take place this is
where a casino but there's so much
there's so much debauchery in Miami yeah
that city would just implode in
Lauderdale that whole Broward date like
accountants and Puerto Ricans I made a
Danny Tom pompano Warnick who when I was
a kid I went to Florida because I my
friend was like hey I won this vacation
yeah you want to go with me I'm like
fuck yeah free vacation it was to
Florida for a couple days and then you
went to the Bahamas for a couple days
oh yeah it turned out to be one of those
things he didn't tell me that it was one
of those things where no it's you you're
looking at condos oh shit
every day you have to look at a condo in
order to get your next ticket for your
next hotel and it was like a full-time
job and so is the war yeah and then
you're paying tax on all these hotels so
like I only like I was a poor kid like I
was like 19 or something like that and
so I only brought a couple hundred
dollars for spending and beer money I
ended up having to borrow money from him
while Nair just to pay for these taxes
and do all this I was so pissed but
anyways we went to Pompano it wasn't
pomp enough for it and I wanted to move
there so bad and now I looking back at
that that's the gauge if I moved can I
tell you one time Tommy now we're
driving from like Miami to Vero Beach
and we stopped at a gas station just a
lot of know where the fuck we were and I
walked in and there was a man wearing
cutoff jean shorts
no shoes a skinny white guy covered in
racist tattoos like clearly it was like
some backwater Klan and I was like I'm
gonna fuckin deaf
oh no no that guy my house that was my
dad you mean and I was like mr. Sikora
and what are you doing where's the steak
yes you guys scared though right at the
you guys I was petrified because I
thought he's gonna pull out a gun and
robbed robbed the clerk for 20 bucks
that's what fucking crazy Hillbillies do
Florida Seminole Florida this is the the
great
like a marketing ploy that has succeeded
that you don't I don't understand how
they were able to do it but somehow
Florida has successfully put out there
the idea that Florida is just beaches
yeah like people are like Oh Florida
male villains they just remember but
they only a lot of people will only
think of Florida as like South Beach
you're like no you don't understand the
state is about that for about four miles
of like nice beaches and the rest
it gets country is shit and yes yeah
people don't realize swamp lands and
shit yeah swamp lay your body could be
your body will never be found lot of
don't sweat Dexter's takes place in
Florida yeah it's a lot of country boys
it's a lot of it's a lot of rednecks
um it's mostly pickup trucks and and but
I like South Beach because I love Puerto
Rican guys jogging on the one and then
they always have their gold chains
this is them in the face and it's like
my favorite this isn't a jogger by the
way if you if you're if you're a fan if
you like Christina and if you're a
Puerto Rican
you're in there sorry you know as a
thing for I love the Ricans yeah choice
Latin man estate oh I love Latin I lived
like daddy yankee I wanted to see him
play live I just I loved all that shit
Malik WA Tommy what about you what about
your Janine Janine haze no that's a
awful oh gee jenna haze what about you
and you're obsessing those two entities
chewing gum next to you am I am I
sitting in the chair that she said it
yes yes get your toe now can you smell
her Oh God and there's gum right there
on the side should I touch this yeah
sure why not take to it I dairy the
chewy I will when was it um it was what
is today Thursday I think was Monday
Monday pretty moist it is still moist
kind of yeah it's she's very lubricated
in well if you're a fan of jenna haze
the superstar porn star or of sam
tripolis what is it
97 naughty show podcast yeah Jenna
sitting where I sat or sat where I'm
sitting and she put her gum very
delightfully on your it's great and it's
still chewy it's great I can oh man what
is that is that a trident wintergreen I
just hope it's not Ashley Hamilton's cuz
I was thinking about I would actually
chew it
yeah but then I'm like if it's Ashley's
gum I don't want to chew it why you
think Ashley dirtier than ya did heroin
Emmeline fucking crazy drugs and he's
he's balding because he has a he had a
foot funk did you hear that oh you guys
got a listener the last 290 show
podcasts have been crazy awesome Ashley
Hamilton George Hamilton's son I was
like this huge music star overseas and
he was about to come over to the United
States with this really good song he
played it and it was actually a really
good song like I was like wow this would
have hit the United States whatever five
years ago six years ago he would have
been like a Smash Mouth or whatever
those like bands that came up during
that time but then he did too much drugs
and his whole shit got thrown away but
anyways he was he had a foot fungus that
was so bad that he went to the doctor
and he got this medication for his feet
and you're supposed to get your levert
liver checked out what like a lot
because I guess his medication fucks
your liver up he didn't do that he
started just losing chunks of hair see
the hair missing and stuff like that so
yeah I would - Jenna Hayes's gum before
I she's okay I tell you what makes me
really happy I know no one gives a fuck
about the royal wedding but I don't I
know I care but can I tell you something
that makes me really happy is the fact
that that Prince William is balding
because it just goes to show you give me
royalty but I can't stop male pattern
baldness and it gives me great joy guy
almost to be handsome - I like him a lot
when you my hair has thinned out lately
yeah I just started just start happening
no no a couple years ago and I did take
a one of the pills yeah I took the pills
for like a month or two I was so
inconsistent and it also lowered my sex
drive really yeah yes it was dead
that I am like you were just about do
you wanna please that I said in that
voice I know is that it seriously make
you like that or you just you just
didn't get boners easy yeah I just
wasn't you know normal one for Tommy you
know he's never soft so this was a very
trying time boy yeah my husband is very
fertile very erect and ready to rumble
it's good to just kind of take that's
right now the hair is basically the same
where it was oh that's cool
yeah I'm gonna wearing a hat but I don't
know I think your hair looks great yeah
you're here I think you're a very
handsome man
thanks bud you're a dashing bear yeah
you're so cute thanks babe look at you
you big old smile easily I did the edge
him I had a toenail yeah I mean I didn't
want to fucking talk about it was it
yellow yeah Oh crunchy and so oh but you
know what now you say that they made me
the the doctor that I went to was right
down on the same street like five
buildings down mm-hmm from the place
that checks your liver they would uh
every time I had an appointment I would
have to get my liver tested first really
yep and then they would give me the
prescription oh my god Henry found that
was the routine for having it refilled
wow that's weird I think my dad had that
problem but he also likes to drink yeah
that's why it's toenails Anil right my
heel here just like it you don't have
noticed here in California though that I
didn't have this when I was in Ohio is
it seems like a lot of not only doctors
but mostly dentist have this whole like
used car salesman salesman ethic where I
go in there and it feels like I'm
getting sold shit that I don't need
oh speaking of oh my god we have the
best story but sorry did you have a
story well I did real quick I went to go
get a cleaning the other day and then I
get a bit I paid for it and then I went
and I just got a bill today and it's
like oh we forgot to charge you you you
got the fluoride treatment and all this
other crap and I'm like whoa whoa I
didn't get no all right treatment what
the fuck is that all bad yeah yeah so I
mean have you guys noticed it's like I'm
trying to go in there they're like you
need to get this gun thing where you can
the numbers of your gum and Maybelline I
tell you but I have a bigger um like
more shocking feeling about this right
and that is that like I do you remember
like as a kid
you viewed like I did the medical
profession as completely ethical yeah
like there is there was no violation of
you know you would not be referred
something that you don't need right I've
always thought that like all doctors are
like this in here and it took till I was
that was Christina it was really nice
actually I was I those ABS I appreciate
it I took till I was like 27 before the
first time I realized like oh no like
they'll try to make money off of you to
like I didn't get so I had the first
thing I had was I was having like weird
a chest kind of just like a pressure
that I kind of like it happening kind of
a lot so I I told my physician he was
well he sent me to a cardiologist
that's the cardiologist was like let's
run we'll do an EKG on you the EKG you
know is a hook you up and they basically
are just reading her heart Ryder a turn
yeah so I I go to this top tier
cardiologist in LA he reads it he goes
you know there's it's slightly off and I
was like well what does that mean he's
like there's a 5% chance that
something's wrong with your heart I was
like 5% same way but then he asked you
what did he ask well he goes he goes uh
wait was it
memories like do you use cuz your own
that's a different thing
that was a different that was first day
they they tested my blood and they're
like you have really high muscle enzymes
and I was like fucking awesome I'm
really strong and they're like they're
like no like off-the-charts and I was
like is that that sounds good yeah it
was like he's like the only people with
really high muscle enzymes or like
Olympic athletes sure and cocaine
addicts oh you're both and I was like
well I don't do okay yeah I know
exercise actually
he was like he was like dude there's two
options and you're definitely not one of
them so how much cocaine you did it was
basically the conversation right I
literally I was like dude I don't do but
in all fairness you look like you do
drugs oh yeah you're not a vision of
health some days I wake up next year
some days I'm like really did you stay
up all night rummaging through trash
you're almost perfect and that's but
that's the love that we share and I
don't always look great either you look
you can't church those fucking doctors
cuz even if you say you smoke or do
anything they put on that chart next
thing you know your insurance company
knows yes and cocaine and some ugh
cigarettes yeah I went in for like
migraines once and now forever they're
like you have brain problems like no I
was on the pill when it gave me
headaches she got an EKG I asked the
guys then he goes um you could just
slightly often I go well says there's a
5% chance that I don't feel comfortable
without running this other test on you
so I was like all right so I go run this
other test the other test is like an
imaging test they inject you with like
radioactive shit and right it's a blood
stream so it sees it go through your
body yeah hard make sure it does
everything really elaborate they'd run
that test and they're like you have like
a slightly bigger heart than most people
you may be heart yeah maybe my baboon
heart is why I have your man man this I
go that's a stronger heart stable lower
sitting heart rate and that's maybe the
confusion that arises when they're like
why is your heart so strong all right
that was like to run a marathon I'm like
extra marathons check me out how's that
so anyways the bill for that was like
eight grand nine grand for the imaging
thing huh we almost died and here's the
best part
Jamie's after this whole saying and I
had you know the health insurance like
you know covered most of it but there's
a whole elaborate thing I tell my dad's
friend who's a cardiologist and like my
whole story he's like well do you have
the EKG and I was like yeah he goes
we'll send it to me I'll take a look at
it and I was like all right so I sent it
to my dad's friend he calls me up
because I just want to tell you that you
have nothing irregular about you it
totally normally
yeah you should have never run that
second pattern and it was just like that
feeling of like really they just did
that yeah make those cocksuckers oh
jesus a human garbage we'll do that same
thing kind of happened to me in a
certain way I had a panic attack
I didn't eat for like I was like a whole
day and I went out and had a couple Red
Bulls or these huge Mountain Dew like
energy drinks anyways I've got some
heart palpitations pulled over thought I
was dying having a heart attack and
called an ambulance and the ambulance
came right dude you're fucked up we need
to take you in and blah blah blah and
I'm thinking you know what I bet they
get a cut to take people to the hospital
and that ambulance charged $800 for a
mile just one month yeah and so I get to
the hospital and they're like oh shit
your heart's acting crazy and so they
didn't flush me with all this crap and
they did all anyways it costs like
$10,000 for an anxiety attack because I
had too much Mountain Dew that came out
of your pocket yes No and that was with
insurance yeah man
you owe 10 grand yeah I paid it all off
thank God no god forbid you have to go
to the emergency room for something real
I mean I fell off a scooter a few years
back and went to the ER I was there for
like an hour it cost thousands of
dollars if they offered they offered me
a vicodin then I was like now I got it
at home and I look on the bill it costs
$50 for a fucking vicodin pill right $50
they charge you owe me you had a scooter
didn't I was not a it was a razor
scooter I'm kind of like children and at
6 and years ago I was really into them
and then I fucking face-planted
face-planted on the pavement and a woman
with her baby was strolling by me didn't
even help me just rolled right past me
and I was like oh I just it was bad I
sprained my arm
oh fuck you know it's funny when you
being an adult trying shit that used to
do as a kid like riding bikes and razor
scooters and stuff I rode a bike the
other day and flipped over the
handlebars you can weigh how bad so you
were just sprained uh well no no what
happened is I actually ended up like I
spy crack my elbow yeah like the bone
something shattered or something not
real anyways I don't give a fuck like I
don't go to the doctor unless I have to
and I went to my doctor and he's like
yeah we got us put a split cast on your
arm like
this you're I'm gonna be straight out
four Watchmen and I said go fuck
yourself
no way and I just you know what the arms
fine now I don't know put anything on
them can't prove this into these
assholes cuz they they don't always know
what's up they don't even know what the
hell you have that's crazy
the same the dentists are the worst uh
Dennis your most egregious or out here
the words like they've been doing this
thing lately where they count every
single T tooth and I put a number one
through five to see how deep your gum is
or something like that anyways then they
yeah they need you to go in there and do
like four different treatments where
they come inside and wash your gums out
like the plaque inside your gum I don't
know there's they're telling me all this
and so I told my mom this my mom's like
yeah they start doing that when you're
really old you know but you should not
be getting it when you're 36 yeah I'm
like what if I just have really bad
teeth in your mouth yeah we don't know
what your mouth has been your mouth
might have been on this government yeah
yeah but Tommy they told you that you
had like here's I have like regular PPO
like where you can ask your dog to help
yeah but my dental insurance was is the
like the cheap one do insurance is
stupid by the way I'm gonna cancel it
yeah anyway so I pay like nothing but
then they're like you can go to this one
dentist you know or they look like a
dental clinic you can go to right so
this is like the second time since I've
been in LA where I went the first time
I'll tell you the first time the first
time I went to a really high-end
dentist's office mhm and it was because
I was working on a show and they had to
some arrangement where they're like you
can get your teeth whitened whitened for
$50 what was the procedure that was
normally five hundred Wow
so I went and uh the guys were like hey
since you're here do you want us just to
like check your teeth and I was like all
right like at the time I was like sure
dog teeth madam is longer big that's
what that does they have to clean your
canines they're like you have like
eleven cavities do you want us to 11
right I was like nah dude and they're
like I mean it's up to you and I was
like no I don't
so then I went to my dentist or the
dentist at the time whatever that was
going to I was like I just went I
explained the story and you checked him
out he was like you zero cavities you
fucking serious this was so anyways a
few more years passed then I go freeze
to go recently to this dentist in town
or whatever that they gave me the
referral like you've my insurance you go
to this guy so I go and they do a
cleaning and then they're like all right
took some x-rays you know you have a 12
cavities do you want us to film wow that
was like fucking serious it's zero
cavity every tooth NASA never went and
now I have 12 and they're like I mean
yeah and I was like no now I had an
attitude about it cuz I had the
experience and I was like yeah no thanks
asshole I don't want to do that and
they're like your choice man your
fucking teeth you do what you want with
you and I was like yeah I'm fine
so thank God she knows like a good
ethical and I tell you Hungarians always
I only go to Hungarian Dennis and doctor
doctors cuz we're Hungarians I have his
name if you're interested yeah I'll give
it out don't give it a don't Maya I
don't know you should give it out but to
plug for him if you want a good dentist
you know me and I will get his day he's
very reputable and he does impeccable
work for a good rate him and I want to
be associated with movies that's a good
point yeah and if they're in Columbus
Ohio got a doctor Straker who is my
childhood Dennis that fucking kicks ass
and never would do this stupid shit so I
go to him and I go I tell him the story
this guy now and he's like I go here the
x-rays cuz they x-rayed me and this
would they told me they gave me
paperwork showing he goes well first of
all they didn't say that you have 12
cavities and I was like oh really that's
what I thought the guy said he goes well
this is the chart that coincides with
the x-ray says you have 19 cavities yeah
I was like what he's like that's what it
says here and I was like did I have 19
cavities that's impossible I know he was
like yeah so he's sitting there reading
it forever and I'm like all right like
he's like hold on I'm just making sure
of everything I'm checking okay you
don't have 19 cavities
I go what do I have he goes you have 34
cavities that was Christina told him to
save oh that's fun are you freaking out
yeah I was like that's like fucking
$200,000 yeah might have Mimi's doing my
step-brother got to the point where cuz
he drank McLaren think he does is any
more me he's drinking the water a
12-pack a mountain do not diet 12 pack a
mountain do every day pack he would
carry a box of 12 pack around with him
and he cut it so he can just grab a can
and still use it as like a suitcase
swear to fucking god it's so weird is he
dead no no but he came one day to
Christmas and all his teeth were pulled
out he's like you know what fuck that
I just gave my whole teeth pulled out
and so now I just got all his tooth and
he's like maybe six years older than me
and he's what does he have dentures or
something yeah now I think he has
dentures and stuff but what he was like
I think he had something like that where
it was like fuck I'm not paying a
hundred thousand dollars for all this
crap I'm just gonna get one my teeth
pulled out wow that's a little extreme I
mean then you have to replace all those
teeth you can't just walk around her
know you can so how many cavities did
you really have just so that people
don't was kind of depressing I ended up
having six yeah that's better than nine
but but you don't floss that I thank you
I don't floss either
I fucking refuse before I'd only lossing
fuck you why all area
I had only ins your friend until I was
until until this week and I only had one
cavity my whole life now look and then
all of them he goes he goes all of the
ones that you have could have been
avoided but they were all between molars
and he's like they all could have been
avoided
right lossing is a flawed boy yeah same
here
oh no no I agree I try it I just can't
do it I still feel good I know I just I
just started doing became addicted time
I know yeah you see how much shit that
you
that's for the best apart right now fuck
man like so didn't realize that that was
sitting between D is the string or this
little fucking nice string blacks get
back and then just you'll be amazed at
how much shit you blow wait can we
please play the clip I'm dying to hear
it okay yeah I'm Tommy this is the best
thing ever
well you know it's I didn't realize when
I saw it I was like happy this this is
so awesome but yeah speaking of
dentistry and getting shit done to your
face well that is a that's a different
way this is what I felt like oh I
cracked the first one all right I just
cracked a filling and I have a crown and
it hurts so bad today this is from um
while we play at first
no no it's some intervention this is
intervention interventions a show on A&E
where people usually are like completely
and crippled the drug addicts it's the
best show that gets down in the end of
the show after they follow them they
have this the intervention where
everybody in the family usually tells
the addict they know it in how much no I
know I'm just saying how much they at
the moment is when they they tell them
how much you mean to them like how much
they care about them and this one is uh
is that moment like somebody's sharing
so they're reading a letter or like I
love you I miss some time whoa somewhere
deep down in my heart
I still love you that's a guy by the way
talking to his father
huh that's a man crying
this is how I feel when we make love Tom
wow that's uh that was the best crack is
it we get a replay on that I would love
to have one especially the beginning
parts of my favorite because I know
somewhere deep down in my heart I still
love you you know the video of it is the
best part
yeah yeah it's amazing it's worth
checking out I mean what else is worth
checking out I still love you
the other the other one is better than
hip hop one the auto-tuning this was
great hold on my heart just jumped and
you exploded him yeah I can't see it's
like millions of homes which one
oh that one's got four million this one
is good why whoa this is good somewhere
deep down in my heart I still love you
it's like an RKO a song
that's good shit that is talent whatever
remix that has talent yeah if you ever
uh you ever having um its own bad day or
whatever you want a hit of that
what's wait what's those songs that's
cry ever is it this well it's called as
what are those songs is it are Kelly
that's like and I broke into your house
oh yeah it was with another man yeah
it's totally like that yeah from the
closet yeah yeah yeah miss la series
yeah in the closet series by the way did
you guys didn't see the new South Park
last night did no fucking hilarious
really she's me the human centipede I
know about it I never saw you need to
see that force is that movie good is
terrible right it's horrible it's one of
those movies out you get really baked
you sit down you watch it you'll hate it
but you can't look away right and then
it's kind of like a pop pop culture
things that I would recommend just
saying and they they um they just like
parity if they parity it and they mix it
in with Steve Jobs and Apple really
doing the new iPad you know already
announcement and it's fucking hilarious
idol I was laughing out loud for
realsies from realsies I still watch
intervention I love it I love it but how
do these people not know they're on the
show intervention at this point like you
know cuz you're you're a junkie you're
watching then they all know the show
they all know you sold your TV what are
you talking oh is that why they all know
everyone knows that show though and they
all know that like the show stars while
you're going my name is Tom oh yeah like
they all spell their name I like to Huff
gasolina yeah it was huffing gasoline
that we saw Oh from rights to whites the
whites documentary you seen that one
right ban no I actually never watched a
full episode of intervention FC no no no
I don't know the documentary the
wild wonderful whites of West Virginia
oh no I still haven't seen it Joe
Joe has this whole thing where he goes
it brings it up almost every podcast
you've seen it writing like no you keep
on saying you're gonna give me a time
about it cuz I'm waiting for you to give
it to me but he talked about a lot he
talked about all the time so they
actually they actually heard about Joe
talking about it and so like the
producers of the Irwin stuff like I sent
Joe like a box of t-shirts really is one
of those t-shirts of dude that's amazing
credible you have to watch I know
total helmet the best is Jesco he's the
one that's been Jessica what he's been
huffing gasoline he's old and he has
brain damage from huffing gasoline they
don't know what part of my brain let it
rot it out but there's a hole somewhere
in my brain and don't know what part
it's affecting right now that is might
have affected the part that made me get
attacked in the Charles Manson yeah wait
it's Manson on one end and Presley an
Elvis Presley but I'll tell you what
that fool can tap-dance he can you can
tap so apparently brain damage is
proportionate to your ability to like
that's family you can't even if you
don't know there's a documentary called
the wild wonderful whites in West
Virginia and it's just profiles it
follows the white family in in rural
West Virginia average but just general
for a year it's incredible like they are
just everybody is either dead yeah in
jail on drugs or some combination of is
there one person that's like the
daughter that's like I got my shit
together mine now rate there's one who
youth kinda has like me he still has the
hillbilly Anna yeah but he left he
there's one that left yeah and he left
to Minnesota and he kind of has his act
together that's but it's incredible man
yeah you have to see this it just goes
to show that you know you really are
born into your limitations I guess you
could say it's hard to transcend if
you're if you're born into being a
hillbilly like if that's all you know
and your DNA is just all fucked up
whiskey hillbilly like there's it takes
a lot to overcome
yeah like flossing for me it is like
flossing for you a great analogy dude
it's fucking off now you know it's
really cool what smells this smells like
shit when you floss oh really
it opens up like a pocket like you're
kind of Wow yeah never thought about
getting veneers yeah yeah but I didn't
then I saw the procedure done I've seen
how they do it yeah they glued shit I'll
shave your teeth down they shave down oh
and then they put those veneers over the
baby teeth can I tell you because I have
to fake front teeth cuz I knew two one
ones are happy yeah
what do you bondings like porcelain I
got one that's porcelain and one x
temporary from 12 years ago that they're
like oh you need to get that replaced
I'm like I know I know but I just
haven't gone back every down a little
bit oh yeah can I say I'm afraid of
veneers cuz I don't want them shaving
down my real tooth I feel weird about
that
yeah I'd rather them just keep doing a
porcelain chopper climb downtown um yeah
I'm really in whoa that's really loud
Wow
now it's off that's uh that's much
better
okay thanks man um yeah I'm real weird
about like for somebody that like I
think about teeth and a very judgy of
teeth I can't believe that I didn't get
into flossing until now yeah Wow lesson
learned lesson we're at six cavities you
got a fucking floss your teeth you got a
plus 40 you're lucky that you just got
cavities I had one tooth because like
when I moved out here I didn't have a
dentist and so the I just decided not to
go to a dentist for several years and I
had a cavity I knew I had a cavity was
one of those ones where I'm like god
it's so sore I know I need to get a
fucking dentist and so I kept on putting
it off playing off and finally I took it
off and I'm like dude your shits fucked
we need to beat her did the dentist say
that exactly yeah he's like holding the
chart upside down you know to the side
and he was like you need to get that
shit fixed and and the only way to fix
it is to either get an implant Oh
bridge and then I'm like what's the
difference and they're like well the
bridge can come undone I am plan is like
the MacBook Pro of teeth and I'm like
all right eNOS how much is that I think
the whole thing costs maybe like $5,000
7 like that
yeah happen to one of my friends and we
moved out here he got like his tooth was
buddy's like my tooth hurts
Mike dude we went to the dentist and
they were like he had some you know it
needed to get like a root canal then he
had some what type something socket
right Oh dry sockets happy yeah but then
some other inspection cigarettes yes and
he had some other infection anyways the
whole thing was like eight or nine grand
out of pocket though oh my god exactly
bad um you know what else fucked you a
bed but where I took you the gym last
week why did you do that this was so
much fun dear man sound sick baby if you
want to have fun you're a guy hey and
your wife or girlfriend hasn't gone
doesn't like work out at all regularly
no not that I'm some fucking fitness
guru right but you box away yeah I do
whatever I hit the heavy bag and I am my
problem with being a fat is it I'm
inconsistent with the gym right I am not
disciplined with eating but like I know
how to you know I've been a competitive
whatever athlete had played sports and I
know how to you know write work out in a
gym so even though I don't go enough I
go to the gym and I usually do like a
decent like heavyweight workout mm-hmm
so I was like hey Juwanna come down to
the gym with me and it was my birthday
right dates like walking and she was
like yeah alright so we walked out of
the gym which is great buying it like
that'll make you go to the gym more
where you can live in a neighborhood can
walk to your gym right having a gay
neighborhood
so it's all gay bears when walking to
the gym it is very very homoerotic gym
but uh we walked down there she's like
alright I'm gonna get on the treadmill
and I was like now workout with me like
just lunch workout with me I was like
unable to do so I made her do leg press
oh my god out of nowhere right I never
done it to like press and then actually
doing and I start laughing and she's
like why are you laughing I was like oh
my god you're gonna be so sore like I
get sore or I do
pretty consistently and I know what it's
like when you haven't done it for months
mmm she did leg she did a leg press leg
extensions leg curls and then she did
like this step I just step stool thing
with rice up crow I was like then I just
started like so stupid
it looks so dumped also done it's not
look look
doing that stuffs doesn't make you look
cool no it does not you know I try to
look dignified him yeah
but I was like every time I looked that
I was like oh my god the pain you're
gonna be in is like it's not even
telegram when I told you I was I was
doing it I was like does it feel good oh
yeah this one is like when I was she was
doing like press she like tried to stop
and I go why you stopping she goes it
doesn't feel good I'm like good we need
to go work out together yes you know
it's you're doing like weight resistance
like it's supposed to burn just like it
does I'm like that's good like telling
it right so skip a meal an attack then
the next day the whole night I'm just
laughing like you have no idea what
you're gonna feel like tomorrow it's
gonna suck so I just kept laughing about
it and then we finally the next day she
was like oh I'm crippled Oh crippled and
she started walking
you know how toddlers walk and they go
like step step that they don't know how
to do a full Bend they don't had a walk
and control their knees ooh that's how
she walked for like six days probably
like three yeah I hate you and then the
best you're like you wanna go workout
today yes I'm like that's never gonna
happen
I was trying to tell her aren't you that
lactic acid buildup is the worst and
it's burning and go workout a loser
yeah yeah it gets better I mean I get
sore from bowling like the other day I
went bowling and my pole like leg and
arm was sore for like just like that for
a damn yeah but that does go away it's a
the worst is working out with Joe Rogan
because Emma sucks I see an animal he's
an animal and he is one of those loud
guys because he will have sex sounds
screaming from him in the middle of
24-hour fitness it's just
like that and it's it's like I have to
go to the other side so like everybody's
like looking back and stuff like that I
guess some gyms have like no grunts I
mean really yeah cuz people have been
kept still
Tommy I will work out with you on the
condition that I get to grunt like that
in the gay gym you heard it she made it
I won't do it if I get to be like or
that shit oh yeah fuck that is that's on
record yeah I've done uh I've gone to
the gym the hotel gym with Joe yeah
wicked gets on the like the elliptical
right but blows it out like a lunatic
yeah like I'm like what like he he
really maximizes the the actual training
tool there oh yeah like wow yeah he's a
he's a maniac looks fit he's so crazy
he's he's super I told I tweet hit that
when we were in Louisville we're at a
bar one night and they actually had the
professional the arm wrestling thing oh
the machine yet like well the thing were
you like oh yeah bro thing laughing yeah
and like so I was like hey jump run over
here real quick like let's do this
dude like I'm not crazy strong but like
you know I figure even if you are murse
was somebody stronger than you get like
kind of a good right like a little tug
of war now it was zero or dude zero
point zero like though it was like yeah
like you know oh it was like he was like
just looking at me like are you I'm like
I'm going as hard as I can and it was
like BAM like I just like you know it
was yeah oh yeah it really put me in
check I was like fuck and that's a girl
I tweeted and some girls like well
you're a fucking retard for thinking
that you could almost I was at a strip
club with Joe and there was this this
woman that was a muscle stripper like
she was one of those girls that like
alright you had him you have a penis or
you had like bodybuilders new body
better this was so scary and and um like
she kept on hitting on me and I was
grossing me out because she was fucking
like huge yeah and Joseph something like
I think Joe said it does you know once
you arm-wrestle Brian or something like
that I'm like okay let's do it and then
like right when we're starting I'm like
if I lose against a fucking stripper
girl
oh that's going to be most embarrassing
thing ever and it it was a fucking war
dude it was like one of those like
hardcore ones where I'm just like all
right I just gotta do that I beat her
you did but I hope we gotta do Joe just
to feel it uh-huh
you got it you bet I don't want to I
felt him you know it sucks
he's craziness yes wrong yeah yeah it's
gonna make a gay joke if I can think I
went I felt more like that when I said
it too I was like I was like I can't
believe that I couldn't even get like a
budge she was like I've been working out
a long time I'm really a train a lot
like nah dude that was embarrassing
yeah I think I've hated physical things
my entire life me too looking yeah all
right even as a child they really go
play I would literally climb on top of
like the bars and take a nap and I
thought fucking hated PE I thought I was
a slow Walker oh yeah there's nobody oh
yeah you really hate and she hates when
you're like she'll be like are we racing
follow down yeah but I'm a slow I'm all
I'm that guy
I'm the guy who's like we take it easy
she's fucking ten feet behind me like
why are we running running I'm like I'm
walking slow right crawling right now
yeah she's just like cuz I'm always like
we like my Arab husband you're always
ten steps ahead
I really had to put on my Birkin yeah
I'm a fast eater in a slow Walker yeah
that's I'm super fast I'm a slow eater
in a slow long you're slow eater I don't
got the slow eating thing like me and my
dad used to always like let's why are we
wasting time meeting him let's get this
shit taken dip don't wait a minute down
okay I tell you what my athleticism when
I was in seventh grade I picked up
smoking cigarettes and that's about the
time they make you run the mile here in
LA and I was like fuck this I would I
would walk the mile and chain smoke the
entire time it took me 20 minutes they
made you run a mile yeah and I do this
shit here in public school in LA you
have to run the mile every Friday and
it's like a hundred degrees and yeah you
see Cassell time right yeah City and
they're like go running out you're like
we just have smog alerts where they be
like it's stage four you can't go
outside a day and then really let's play
touch football fuck you you really I
hate physical activity are you like test
I like tennis because it's not a team
sport I'm not a team player
it's great
and I hate team sports here's what
really happened I believe actually now
that I think about it when I developed
breasts
once you have titties there's no running
right I've got huge cans I've got D size
not to brag I'm not really that pleased
with it cuz I don't want to run it hurt
you have a lot of back issues hurts my
tits
yeah shoulders and stuff oh yeah man you
have to give her a lot of massages titty
massage sure but you know I said to this
yesterday on the Rogan podcast I just
found out you're not supposed to like
finger girls butthole and then put it in
her vagina oh it's very verboten yeah so
you have to look it off in between how
did you find this out from Jenna or from
Jo Jo Jo told you know I know a girl
told me oh really yeah I mean cuz I
don't finger buffle as much I just
recently started you know oh yeah you
know most girls don't let you learn some
stuff like did you ask questions to
Jenna about like like you know details
like that no I mean I'm pretty solid
with most things that's one of those
things thing actually educate you on
anything nah not really it was just more
I mean she was just a very interesting
person yeah sure yeah I would highly
recommend less than that but you know
it's like that's one of those things
that if I thought about Mike yeah that
makes no sense why would put a finger in
your asshole and put in your pussy is
bad for you but one of the things that
you know you're all drunk and having sex
with the you know you're not thinking
that kind of shit you're not like oh
which finger was that ago I better use
this fingernail yeah yeah you have to
kind of got to remember that yeah and
remember the finger yeah and keitel you
guys hands are generally not clean yeah
yeah girls if you're listening always
tell your guy to wash his hands before
he puts his figures right and you said
your name should watch here we fuckin
now
you should watch a guy according to
somebody that we met yeah should always
watch a guy wash his hands with
antibacterial soap before he puts them
inside of you who said that that's what
a Kayla said oh wow that's right right
she's a porn she is adults you can't say
porn they don't like the word points or
yeah I'm sayin it's dull
I accept one star bitch they don't like
it they have to call it a dolt
oh sweet let's can we cover this one
then we got to wrap this up all right so
okay this just to tell everybody this
there is a guy in our neighbor Oh Huey
we haven't talked about this um and um
please wash your hands after you finger
a girl's ass but by all means or guys
but um this guy in our neighborhood we
used to have a very famous or you know
neighborhood famous guy the Silver Lake
Walker who would walk 20 miles a day she
came every day mm-hmm he was this
lunatic he's a doctor apparently and he
he spent the last 20 years of his life
walking through Silver Lake every day
and only wearing aqua blue shorts
shirtless shirtless and sneakers and
reading a paper trail fin and jerk eat
and write and he just became known as a
Silver Lake walk the Silver Lake Walker
and he just died though how good is that
Mexican Coke no we got red banner me
yeah he died in his hot tub um they
believed that there were drugs involved
but whatever he was the guy so now that
he's gone you need your neighborhood
like quirky guy right all right so this
guy was around before but he was totally
overshadowed by the Walker
so yeah this guy is the Birdman of
Silver Lake and what he does is he
pushes a he's not like like not like the
Birdman like with Lil Wayne this guy
pushes a shopping cart up and down
Hyperion and he has bird feed and he
throws out bird feed bags over huge
massive like he needs a shopping cart
he's at the attenti bike and he calls
out two pigeons and feed
so pigeons shit all over businesses was
in excess total menace is total for it
yeah but he really cares these birds any
post signs on a shopping cart like slow
down there squirrels everywhere just
trying to protect girls in the pigeon
song any any posts he post signs all
over Hyperion always like you know have
you seen people taking down my my my
posters he's putting up posters that's
actors yeah about the posters it um well
he also he also sweeps the sidewalks -
yes really nice yeah he's sweet and then
cookie shoes video acted but yeah he we
saw his cart parked in front of video
active it's a video store it's a video
sober a gay gay hardcore video still
yeah I'm not gonna go inside yes forgive
me that shaking a walked in there here
we go inside jerk-offs I think we were I
think there's a room with this guy Todd
comes in uh uh but there's uh anyways so
we were looking him up and he's also an
actor and there's there's a link to
movie that he made
that's what bird guy the burger is that
guy so if you click on that the second
link with the the timecode they're
actually the the third link is really
good too when we just click the third
one all right so he's from Italy and he
came to the u.s. Deacon actor and that
kinda didn't you know pan out a guest is
what he wanted and he put his yeah this
is his um one who scenes Frank Massimo
is the name that he goes by Franco
Massimo is his Oh actor name yet alright
on let me get this fucking Frank oh my
Athena you might you know you know
Dennis Woodruff is kind of fucking
problems I want you to go back call Tony
and tell him that there was one guy
yeah I want to know I want to know where
the other guy is and I want to know that
by the night otherwise we're gonna have
a fucking problem here so call Tony now
here it is oh shit you all I'm full of
money are you gonna pay
I need help more days both no you gonna
pay now don't have it right truly kid's
gonna pay right now
he puts his phone number on you got a
wherever Ichi
get me Joey with you okay if you don't
mind Ricci you don't mind can you set up
that first clip with the the I think the
1:13 is where it starts where he's just
sitting at the yes um this is what it
you know this is a whole part of
Hollywood this under belly of these
people that yeah
it's Dennis Woodruff I used to be
obsessed I would go talk to him
yeah I thought okay he got a phone call
from the gun watch somebody in Davis
comes down to whack somebody in the
biscotti it's undeniable how they seem
to know just just tell me something
what's going on
I cannot somebody
and I love the artistic camera I can
somebody I love when it mafia guys say I
cannot lack some that I have been with
the stubby family more than 15 years
bananas
for more than time and I'm not going to
jeopardize my friendship he's using a
pain for this kind of family
caboose can be hopping listen listen
just because you had the bad day I'm not
gonna watch somebody because she lost
some money
all right
I come there next week and we can talk
about I'm not gonna walk anybody it was
kind of family I think we established
that storyline I know you wouldn't
actually watch this whole clip when you
weren't here and he actually repeats
that whole I'm not going to whack
somebody at least 50 times and it's like
to me it looked like that they were
actually filming it and they were going
to edit it yeah yeah because like the
cameraman goes from the top like above
him like they're just holding the camera
above his head yeah - like I'm going to
the ground and as a as a camera guy that
just drives me crazy
it feels so bad like I watch and I go
did who told this guy that you you
should use this dialogue for this look
no you know what shocks me is seeing him
wearing clothes cuz he's right surely
he's also sure the boys for some reason
shirtlessness is just part of being a
Silver Lake weirdo is yeah you can't
have a shirt on
that's so weird yeah this was weird
about LA yeah these people walking
around with birds and shit like that you
don't realize oh wait no they're also an
actor oh they're in the industry I read
an article we look - Kristina found an
article that you read it and like he's
waiting for his break which is another
consistent theme of kind of the weirdos
that you know inhabit every neighborhood
in LA is that they all really believe in
the like the real discovery thing of
like no I'm gonna be at 7-eleven buying
a fucking protein bar yeah and I guys
gonna be like you wanna want to be in a
movie like they really think that that's
gonna have to happen
he thinks that like by walking up and
down Hyperion Suns gonna be like oh hey
hey man hey come here a second you know
the way you work those pigeons
now let me ask you do you think it ever
ever has happened where a director is
like you eating the cheese yes it does
who who
well did from in sync the guy that
created in sync I went to Longhorns
steak house I think it was huh and grab
one the bussers is like hey I like your
look let's get in a band
yeah Wow it's happening I did hear
Edward fro getting cast in the
Terminator films that way that whoever
was and you hear about a lot of those
it's only what models have gotten
discovered like that Marley's different
yeah they get welcomed and is each
other's people that book book
big jobs on their first audition -
that's an audition that's I'm gonna try
yeah yeah and I got shoot like that
fuckin what's-his-name that cutiepie
married to the cougar the Cutie Demi
Moore's husband Oh Ashton Kutcher yeah
he's got one of those go fuck yourself
stories or easily yeah I just decided I
wanted to be an actor then the first
thing I was a 70 show so it's one of
those stories makes when a boy I think
that other guy that kind of looks like
him the Josh Hartnett remember that guy
yeah he's one I think that booked he
booked like a major movie on his first
ever road it makes me want to kill
myself so Ed's what what first audition
audition they're like and you're in Star
Wars been plugging away at this for 10
years
I want to go on an audition so bad I
don't even know how to start what do you
mean I just want to try it you know just
because I that's one thing I've never
done is gone on it really is you realize
this after you've done a while you talk
to like like basically more working
actors right how much of it is luck is
it lottery you're good you're almost
you're playing the lottery because it's
so much commercial and theatrical stuff
commercial especially is that you're
being cast for the most part on what you
look like yeah and like does it do you
look like what the the brand or the
director feels like the part calls for
you literally walk in the room that can
be like it's just a format like if
they're like it's not the look right I'm
just like you want to read the line and
you're just doing like thanks look it's
because you didn't look like the guy
alright if you look like what they
imagine the part is then you're in the
running you know and then for theatrical
stuff you basically if you if you're not
established you're basically not
inconsiderate yeah and I don't even
fucking like that that just also becomes
like unless you're fucking amazing at
the part right they want to go with a
guy who they feel like is a bigger name
it's just better for the production you
know all right can I tell you my
favorite kind of audition when you're
you have to prepare things like you have
to prepare like three characters three
impressions for like comedy stuff
one time I auditioned for a show and the
casting lady was typing her email the
entire click had her laptop fully up and
like yeah like didn't even watch me
audition why
and you have to do it you have to run
through your characters and run through
your shit and they don't pay attention
you that's them it's so crazy I don't
know you don't shoot at all he was rich
he was looking at looking at his monitor
one time ah stuff it's devastating the
other one is when they go you get you
get the sides right and they're like you
know be like three different scenes and
they're like just prepare these and
you'll prepare prepare prepare and let's
say seem to has five pages of dialogue
and you're just like you keep getting
reading it over you haven't memorized
you like I'm ready for this audition you
go into like we're just doing scene 1
so if you want to just go ahead and you
can sing rain you're like what about
like we're not gonna seem to now right I
do they were just going to scene one
you're like awesome
I just yeah I like re always like he
does it all the time auditions and stuff
like that
he books a lot of stuff he books a lot
of shit in like a lot of this shit he
tells me to let he does it's so
interesting is like like he did one from
Miracle Whip and look and he was like
you know you're supposed to go in there
and just talking about Miracle Whip or
act like you like Miracle Whip but he's
like you know what I fucking hate
America was just a bash in Miracle Whip
and just so happens that's exactly what
the commercial campaign was so that's
what I guess you have to do is my choice
like a hard choice yeah just be so they
remember you
yeah do you bro do you know bro
situation
yeah doors you should go can I tell you
that one commercial I got for kellogg's
raisin bran
I went in with the worst shittiest
attitude and I started eating off for
craft service table I went straight I
was like and they're like you can smile
you know that's what the casting
director said to me no like oh shit
sorry and I ended up getting it cuz I
have shitty attitude you know one day
wanted for the part I post one where I
just came in and I was like hey go fuck
yourself any attitude and the idea of
the commercial was that your thumbs
could talk so it's really that you hold
your thumbs up and you do the thing like
this but you improvise and I was just
like funny and just you know like
whatever I was just like big and and
they were like that was great man like
can we you know take your picture like
this and then I got the call hey you
booked it we shoot you know blah blah
blah and I was like great so then we go
and you know you're going to do this one
there's all different actors doing
different thumb scenes and they're going
to do
all in post create like a mouth on your
thumb and like hair and like all these
different personalities that are your
thumbs and so we're doing the scene in
the mill again your next one is the hot
tub one I'm like alright so me and this
girl are in this hot tub we're doing
this and then I realize they're like hey
what's going on man
like I hear that but like what's going
on Tom's dumb and I'm like what's the
problem
I look I bite my cuticles and my thumb's
like I chew on them like nervously weird
right like now even this card will get
calloused and I'll chew it oh we don't
know if you've ever seen someone's hands
after they're soaked in water like a
moon but if you bite it gets like really
gross looking like where you chew
becomes like really it stands out more
and it looks really gross and they're
like all the like the production was
like what the fuck's wrong with your
thumb man I was like oh yeah I chew that
and they're like holy shit that looks
really fucked up right now and they had
to cover like with a scarf they used
like bubbles that covered bubbles all
around this thing in their lives that
doesn't look good man that looks really
bad that's fucking gross it was really
disgusting oh yeah and I was so shamed
and I was just like acting like I'm not
it's so humiliated by it that's
disgusting yeah that's good so what have
you ever tried not to do these still do
it I mean are you what biting your
thumbs or do you I don't do that anymore
and actually a few weeks ago I got like
a real complex about my nail biting
mm-hmm I stopped for three full weeks
and my nails grew completely out yeah
and then cochineal going yeah I was very
proud of it and then I the way I started
to break again was I was doing two spots
one in Orange County one in LA
and I got stuck in traffic yeah and I
started biting my nail okay and then
just all in downhill again and it's
worth it there you go
all right Shelly all right let's grab
the shit I did enough right
yeah mommy oh are you around locally
mommy any spots yeah yeah if you want to
see the buns machine that's me I'm going
to be doing spot in Brea tonight
Thursday night tomorrow night Friday I'm
at the Melrose improv on the APM show Oh
tomorrow night yeah and Saturday night
I'm doing this bar in Hermosa Beach
called the 705 bar yeah yeah um I'll be
at the Comedy Store Friday night I think
11 o'clock but the show starts at 9:00
so you can hang out like Oh what about
you um might be having a UFC podcast
Saturday drunk-ass were supposed to but
I was just informed that I also might be
camping this weekend so I'll fuck your
lady friend
yeah let's do go camping in Malibu which
is kind of weird
hey good wilderness and Malibu go do it
for research please find out how that is
yeah I like him you guys like camping no
no no never done it in my life
well not in LA girl man I was city girl
that's all you lazy you guys want Boy
Scouts and Girl Scouts are very jungle I
did I did do Boy Scout see you don't you
don't like camping either no I'm not
really into that that's why we got
married
Wow all right yeah I think it's kind of
cool for one night the promise is after
one night it's it's kind of like yeah I
definitely don't on a lot of it no
thanks
but it's cool because we're looking at
like campgrounds and like this one
campgrounds like uh Wi-Fi available free
Wi-Fi and I'm like wait a second here I
like to pee and wipe and shower and I
just don't like sleeping on fucking
ground like that yeah yeah there's I
don't I like like air conditioning and I
tell you the biggest dumb racket is that
Burning Man we've been in Burma oh okay
that's interesting you said that I was
just talking about Burning Man have you
been there
yes I was working on a TV show where we
went and I've never at 10:00
as an attendee but it's just filthy like
all that dust and your ass goes every
year huh Moshe really and he doesn't he
doesn't party you know cat Moshe kasher
casshern quatre
kasher there's an don't you don't get
angry but I didn't pronounce his let me
there you - wait getting angry like it's
my fuckin side i'm purpose you defended
him like he was related I was thinking
about going actually like getting an RV
a year talk to most don't you'll kill
you I mean if you like to be clean well
that's what I'm saying
like rent and nice or I can't believe I
think I thought a lot of people go
because they like to get fucked up you
get fucked up right drink or do drugs
oh that's what well it's very cool arts
art wise it's cool to see what people
make they make this amazing like floats
and shit out of like cars and bicycles
and it is spiritual and cool it's hot as
fuck and it's dry and dirty and the only
important what do you where do you see
it just sleep in your tents whatever you
want you have to bring your own and you
have to clean it as you leave it's just
a lot it's a lot
no it's involved no you will not see the
buns machine- we're an RV you know RV I
would do I can do an RV but I'm not
fucking around I just want to go there
to see all the the hippy tits
there's a lot of it beat it
well um tune in next week to listen to
your mommies we'll probably have a minor
guest with us we're gonna have a mama
yes are you gonna get uh we don't want
to say I don't want to say it's a
sacrifice yeah super famous no no she is
famous she is famous she's in films and
she's one of my dearest dearest dear
really really funny super funny super
cool very exciting tune in next week
Megan Megan Fox yeah but she does she
does she's topless a lot she does on top
of us Emily knows yeah whoa so I'm
accessible ain't no she's wonderful
lover it's a good time